hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on move university comm
thank you and enjoy so if you recall
from part seven on lipids we talked
about plasma lodgings as being
glycerophospholipids with ether linkages
and that ether linkages is shown here in
in place basically of an ester linkage
which is normally there because of an
acyl group which is the case actually at
carbon number two here but plasma
legends have an ether linkage at carbon
number one of the glycerol backbone and
they also have they're also another
characteristic they have is they have
the first two carbons of the R group
attached at carbon number one those two
carbons have a double bond between them
they have desaturation there in addition
otherwise actually the plasma lajjun is
essentially a glycerophospholipid where
X is some alcohol that's attached there
as part of the polar head group now the
question might be okay plasma legends
they are closed for phospholipids but
they are slightly different because
these two reasons question is how does
each these things get there how does
that ether linkage get there has that
degree of unsaturation get there how
does that happen
so let's investigate it a person that
happens is we're going to have
dihydroxyacetone phosphate which is
basically going to be the glycerol
backbone we're going to take that and
we're going to join it to an acyl Co a
and this a soakaway has these little
asterisks next to it and the reason why
is because it's associated with this
question up here is the identity of this
a soakaway important in determining the
identity of the end product plasma logic
that's something that we can't known
right now we have to go through look at
the pathway and once you've done come
back and see whether or not this
particular a so go it was important
around but until then we'll we'll just
go through the pathway all right so the
haps three carbons are going to be the
glycerol backbone essentially so we take
it we join with this a SoCo a and what
happens is that the coenzyme a portion
falls off and we connect that acyl group
- carbon number one of the
dihydroxyacetone phosphate which gives
us one acyl dihydroxyacetone 3 phosphate
one acyl because it's acyl group of the
one carbon two hydroxy acid tone
becoming from D AB and three phosphate
this is a phosphate on carbon number
three now aside from that we have
another a sylco a and what we're going
to do with this a so close we're going
to turn it into an alcohol so in order
for that to happen two things have to
occur first thing you have to do is get
rid of coenzyme a so the first thing i
have to do but in the process we have to
consider that we're losing that coenzyme
a in addition we're turning this
carbonyl here into a no h and alcohol
hydroxyl group so that was a reduction
reaction and the reducing agent that's
going to be used there is NADPH so NADPH
is oxidized to nad b-plus
while the carbonyl the carbon here
specifically the carbonyl carbon is
reduced to having a hydroxyl group and I
labeled this other carbon over here as
the alpha carbon just a second it can
help us track these carbons so we can
see exactly what's going on here now
question over here is why NADPH just
because we're talking about biosynthesis
so reductive biosynthesis makes sense
okay moving on next thing that happens
is that we're going to take this one
acyl dihydroxyacetone 3 phosphate and
connect it with this alcohol in fact
precisely what we're going to do is this
this acyl group here will be displaced
by this alcohol portion okay so what
happens here is these two things come
together this acyl group comes off as a
fatty acid and we end up having that
that a chain there replace this this
acyl group so now at carbon number one
we have that acyl group there or just
give me that alkyl group there which
actually changes the name of this
molecule and now we actually have this
ether linkage so we have this ether
linkage here
where
as before we had right this portion here
which is the ester linkage so the ester
linkage is basically replaced with an
ether linkage that is accomplished by
the enzyme one alkyl dihydroxyacetone 3
phosphate synthase named for the product
of the reaction so once we have that we
have that alkyl group at carbon number 1
what's going to happen is that we're
going to convert this molecule to this
this molecule over here and the
difference between these two this this
new molecule is one alkyl glycerol
3-phosphate the difference between these
two is basically at carbon number 2
carbon 1 and 3 they're the same carbon 2
there's an alcohol instead of a carbonyl
so that's a reduction and the enzyme
that catalyzes this reaction is one
alkyl dihydroxyacetone 3 phosphate
reductase named for the fact that it's
acting on this one alkyl
dihydroxyacetone phosphate that is a
mouthful goodness gracious
ok and the reducing agent here for this
reductase is NADPH again ok so that
gives us this alcohol so one alkyl
glycerol 3-phosphate now from an alcohol
gristle role 3 phosphate we get one
alkyl to a sublist or L 3 phosphate so
the difference here is that we now have
at carbon 2 an acyl group so where's
that acyl group coming from it's it's
coming from the reaction that is
catalyzed by one alpha withdrawal 3
phosphate acyl transferase and where is
this enzyme getting the acyl group well
acyl transferase is we've seen them
before in the previous videos we get
them from a so Koei's so we have an acyl
co a come in here and a coenzyme a will
fall off giving us this molecule here
it's not one alkyl is an alkyl group at
the 1 carbon there's a - acyl or to a so
glycerol to eight the 2 carbon has the
acyl group there and of course 3
phosphate so
next up we're going to take that
basically have some alcohol here this X
is some chain some some alkyl chain or
some sort of chain of an alcohol whose
hydroxyl group is right here and this is
going to be added such that it's
attached to the phosphate portion to
give you the polar head group and so
that is head group attachment once we
have this we're nearly done we know they
have our plasma logic the only thing
that we need still is to have the degree
of unsaturation here between these first
two carbons of the alkyl portion on
carbon number one of the glycerol
backbone and so in order to give our
final product this plasma lajjun here we
have a mixed function oxidase a mixed
function oxidase act on this and the
mixed function oxidase requires NADH
as molecular oxygen which will be
converted into water to give us this
final product it's our plasma legend now
what I want to do is go back to that
question that we asked earlier about the
a sub Co a this green one this green
acyl Co a is the identity of this acyl
Co way important in determining the
identity of an particle as knowledge at
well this is a green one right what
happened to it in our product is it in
our product no it's not there we lost it
we actually lost in the step here when
these two components came together and
the alcohol displaced it so that acyl
group is gone as a fatty acid so the
identity of this plasma lajjun is
dependent only on the brown the brown
acyl group basically that we came from
and the blue a soaked away that we came
from labeled R 2 and R 3 so this one was
important in determining the overall
structure and identity and so was this a
soaked away but this guy was actually
not important because it ended up just
leaving right here anyway I hope that
video was helpful in trying to
understand class knowledge and synthesis
thank you for watching
thanks for watching don't forget to Like
comment subscribe and be sure to share
the video with anyone who you think
might find helpful thanks and happy
studying